I do do other things,
whether it's podcasting all the time
or doing the UFC commentary, like,
you know, if I'm, if I watch some
fights and I started posting about MMA,
I'm not trying to be funny and it's
just, it's just what it is, you know?
Well, yeah, you're, you're, you're
living in a lot of different worlds, but,
and I look at your Instagram,
you're cooking meat, right? Yeah.
But for me, I'm thinking, how the
hell does he get the meat? Uh,
like from, from top to bottom, like medium
rare throughout, you know, like that's,
for me, that's more of a learn.
I can teach you Sebastian,
I could teach you, you, the
key is cooking it slowly. Okay.
So you got like this grill
or whatever Drager yeah,
it's a pellet grill pellet grill.
If it gets my meat the way Jimmy,
well in La,
well, I'll have them send you
100%. Perfect. Um, but yeah,
he's the only one of those are,
do you know how they work? No. Oh,
it's fucking fantastic. It's, it's uh,
like say if someone wants to make
a desk like this out of hardwood,
like this oak, the saw dust,
they take the saw dust from,
from saw mills and they compress it and
they make these little tiny pellets.
And so there's no chemicals, no
nothing. It's just wood. And then the,
the way a pellet grill works is a bunch
of really good companies that make, um,
uh, I use a trigger, but I've used
a Yoder that's a great one too.
And Green Mountain grills, that's
a great one. This, uh, they have,
they're all worth the same way. They
have a heating element and a worm drive.
So you have this big bucket of these
pellets and then the worm drive feeds the
pellets into this heating element and
the heating element makes the pellets
catch fire.
So once they catch fire,
it's a matter of how much pallets
and how much fan to keep the,
that's what it looks like up there.
So then
see, look at this job. Yeah, no,
I'm looking at this and I'm like,
that looks like a, that looks
like a lot of work. First of all,
you've got to get a pet, a side
pellet, the catchall, but it's there.
It comes with the whole thing. Yeah, but
then you've got to go by the pellets.
I'll have it delivered to you.
I'll have it to live.
I'm trying to get more people to
cook like this because it's just
would in fire. It's the
best. There's no chemicals,
there's no bullshit and hold
lighter fluid, no gas, no nothing.
So your entire me fire,
your entire meet process is on this grill
except the end at the end.
This is a different grill than I have
because this one has a thing on the side.
If you see that thing on the,
on the right hand side is
like a like that looks like a,
like a direct flame thing. Looks
like it's got gas as well. Right.
The one that I have doesn't have that,
but at the end I sear it at the
very end on a cast iron frying pan.
So I cook it from between 225 to
275 degrees, which is pretty low,
and I'll kick it until it
hits an internal temperature,
depending on what I'm cooking.
Some are around one 22 the maximum,
like one 30 ish.
Then I take it out and then I have
a cast iron frying pan is hot as a
motherfucker and I use either a beef
tallow or grass fed butter and I see her
that shit out of that with some garlic
and I throw some time in there and
forking,
flip it over and get that good senior.
And then I let it sit for
a minimum of 10 minutes.
I think he's realized that mother Oh.
Oh,
okay. So you're, you're
me is unbelievable.
I've seen it on the thank you care
when you say that it's the girl.
So I do something similar, but I do it
in the oven. I don't do it. That'll work.
I do a slow cook in the
oven and then I take it out.
I let it rest for I think 15 minutes
and then I do a sear job. Oh.
But I'm always looking for
better ways to cook meat.
And, uh, if, if you're saying
that this Palette thing, uh,
does it add any flavor?
And that's what's good about it because
it's smokey hardwood. Gotcha. So you're,
it's all smoke. You lift the thing up,
smokes coming out of it and everything.
It's a nice aromatic,
smart, that's what I know.
It's like cherry smoke or oak or you know,
Hickory or maple,
all these different hardwoods. You could
choose a bunch of different. Perfect.
Okay. So we're not getting that in
the, in the oven. No, I need, no, no,
it's different.
And there's also a setting on a trigger
called super smoke where you hit it,
it goes to, it can't be over 225,
but that's what I like anyway.
And you put it on two 25 and it just
constantly fans hard and pushes all this
smoke.
So it just gets his deep rich smoky
flavor in the meat Molly's but a,
I like, if you're not into that
too. I like a regular Weber Grill,
like one of those little fucking Weber a
that, you know, the little Hibachi. Yeah.
What are those things called that you get?
What would you call them?
Like a drum looks like a half a drum.
Like a barrel fucking thing. Yeah.
But what are those, those way it looks
like it looks like a cuts like a black uh,
yeah. The black ones
like steal those. What?
I like those with, uh, just lump charcoal,
that puts a nice flavor on it too.
The key is don't fuck
around with the chemicals.
When you start using lighter
fluid in shit that, that,
that adds weird tastes to your food does.
Yeah.
And even if you buy that lump charcoal,
those charcoal briquettes rather
the charcoal briquettes there's,
there's something in them that makes them
that shape. They have to, and then they,
they, you know, they light fast. Yeah.
Cause it's just fucking gasoline in them.
Like,
but lump charcoal,
meaning they just take hardwood and
then they burn that shit down to took,
you know,
that clunky looking lump charcoal.
Just get that stuff and then take some
newspaper and rolled a newspaper up.
And one of those you ever used one of
those little, uh, um, those chimneys,
do you know what those things are? No.
It's a barbecue chimney. It's like a,
you pour the charcoal in this tube and
at the bottom of the tube you take like
pieces of paper and your
crump alarm up balls,
and then you like the balls on fire and
the fire rises up from the paper to the
charcoal and it lights the charcoal on
fire and then you dump the charcoal out
into the grill. And that, that puts a
nice flavor on it too. That's just a,
but it's again,
same kind of feeling.
It's like would just this wood
flavor on the meat that's nice. Sold.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm, I'm, I'm a
big fan of cooking. I love it.